[Music]
so I'm an eternal optimist about how and
why we should continue to innovate every
aspect of our lives and whether that's
science and technology imbuing more
efficiencies in how we run businesses
but also how we deliver healthcare and
education so as far as I'm concerned
I've adopted the same lens as we think
about the political process so just to
give you some flavor for some of the
proposals on the politician side I
consider the argument that we should
perhaps increase the pay of politicians
and actually force them to justify their
compensation Singapore is a great
example of this model in Singapore the
head of state the Prime Minister earns
over 1.4 million dollars a year in
compensation but to me what's even more
interesting is that the ministers who
are responsible for education and health
care and infrastructure etc earn 30 to
40 percent
bonuses based on certain metrics and
outcomes so how GDP performs where the
life expectancy increases where the
inflation declines I think that that is
a very interesting model for us to
explore because I think it could impose
discipline by the way a discipline
around reward for performance which we
already see and it applies to many of us
as we work in the private sector so
certainly worth the kind of
consideration I think that that could
actually force politicians to think a
little bit more long-term another
proposal on the politicians side is to
basically think about minimum standards
for politicians and this is an idea that
really for me stuck out as I thought
about how the British Parliament looked
back in the 1950s and 60s in that period
the average age was higher on average
about 60 years old but also the skill
set was incredibly varied they had
teachers lawyers doctors farmers and so
people had had other careers and had a
better understanding of how the economy
works because they came to become
parliamentarians having experienced
different sectors of the economy today
I'm to some of those citations that I
reference in the book the average age is
closer to 40 years old
and many politicians actually have no
experience except having been
professional politicians and I think
that that can be quite a disservice in
terms of the canoe not really
understanding the complexity of how an
economy works third I just very quickly
give you one more example of how or what
we might consider in terms of
politicians is we might think about
extending the terms of political office
this is essentially to get away from
this idea of having elections every two
years as we do in the United States
Mexico is an example of a country where
the president is in office only once for
six years and so I think you get away
from this desire for politicians to
constantly court or attempt and try to
seduce voters with policies that may be
short term appealing but over the long
term are incredibly damaging for the
economy and ultimately for for
generations to come
Brazil the Senators have 8 to 9 year
terms again it's really picking on this
theme of extending the the thinking to
better match the economic challenges and
economic headwinds that the global
economy faces
[Music]
you